doing what you love and living within
the means of what that thing pays you
whether it's fifty thousand dollars or
fifty million dollars is the game you
know many people make a million dollars
a year very stressed right now because
they overextended themselves they bought
a plane and a house and a second house
and a third house and hard to get
sneakers and watch right it's not about
how much you make it's how much you save
it's how you manage it and most
importantly your relationship with your
own values and who you are money is not
going to make you happier it's just a
proven fact we have to stop acting like
it does